you know what young women now and you
you could probably speak to somebody
from your own experience but I I know
talking to my my son's friends more
generally there's a really strong script
for young women there it's a very
different script to the one than mums
their mums or grandmothers were it was
you're going to be a wife and you're
going to be a mother maybe if you work
it will be part-time but that's your
primary role a new script for women is
get educated become economically
independent become empowered and make
sure you can stand on your own two feet
it's a really positive powerful script
for young women now Fant and wonderful
but what's the script for men now we've
torn up the old mail script for good
reason what's the new mail script
where's that where's the sense of you
know ambition and where are the messages
we're sending to our boys about about
their education and their independence
their empowerment and the answer is
we're not and so then they end up
drifting and it's not their fault it's
our fault
foreign
[Music]
it is my pleasure to have joining me on
forward senior fellow at the Brookings
institution the author of The Incredible
and important new book of boys and men
why the modern male is struggling why it
matters and what to do about it Richard
Reeves welcome Richard
thank you for having me on Andrew
looking forward to this yeah me too uh
congratulations for taking on this
important topic so Brookings just a
level set for everyone Brookings is
generally considered the number one
think tank in all the land and you are a
wonk uh an economist like what was your
work in prior to examining uh what's
happening with boys and men yeah I think
I have to correct you already Andrew I
think it's number one in the world
sorry about that right just like the
Brookings fun people are going to kill
me if I don't correct you it's like the
global number one thing
um and interesting when I when I moved
to the US from from the UK in 2012 I'd
served in the government over there my
wife said to me what is where would you
most like to work like where's the dream
job for you and I said scholar of the
Brookings Institution
uh and then I'm really fortunate that
that is exactly where I landed uh and
that's because Brookings institution is
is the non-partisan it's authoritative
our values are quality Independence and
impact which means that we can do our
work without looking over one shoulder
or the other worrying about Which senate
is going to call you or just you know do
the best you can and my work previously
is focused mostly on on economic
inequality and lack of upward Mobility
what are the barriers to people being
upwardly mobile and that was true in the
UK and now in the US and that gets into
issues of class differences in the US
obviously race differences in the US but
that then led me to this new Focus
because I on boys and men because as I
was doing that work I just kept
stumbling across these inequalities that
actually were were troubling and which
didn't go the way you would expect to go
when you talk about gender equality you
presume you're always talking about
women and girls sometimes you you still
over but increasingly we now have to
look at the problems facing boys and men
and so that that my work on inequality
and family and class led me to the new
focus on boys and men so you opened the
book
um with the fact that some people try to
warn you off this topic
then you end the book saying that
everyone actually is interested in the
topic
which made it feel like there's this
undercurrent
um but people hadn't publicly uh
spoken about it and kind of were afraid
to
yeah I I one of the reasons I ended up
tapping the subject was because so many
of the people that I was talking to this
was the issue right the school Gates
over the dinner table over at lunch
break uh people were talking about their
sons they were talking about their
brothers their uncles and just how they
were struggling either in school or in
the labor market but particularly if
they were on the on the center left that
wasn't something they took out into
public that was something that would
remained private so they felt like there
was this gap between a lot of the
private anxiety people are feeling
including among many liberals and the
public discourse around this issue and
so it was almost like it was like it was
the inequality that Daniel speak its
name at least from the center left and
and so it was into that space that I
really felt I was trying to some extent
bridge the gap between the school gate
conversations and the political
conversations where there's really been
a deafening silence especially on the
center left and then a weaponization on
the right which I'm sure we'll get into
yeah so let's get this out of the way
really quick um I I wrote a book the war
on normal people that delved into some
of the issues that are facing men
particularly as their most common
livelihoods have been uh automated or
globalized away and it's not a zero-sum
game where you can be concerned about
boys and men and uh still be very much
for uh elevating women in areas is that
they've been discriminated against in or
marginalized or generally advocating for
gender equality the argument you make is
that look gender equality is gender
equality in the sense that if there are
Realms that one gender is is really
really falling behind and for example
Boys in school that also is gender
equality and it's a very legitimate
thing for us to be concerned about and
try to address
yeah that's right and and you know
credit to you Andrew and also you were
kind enough to endorse this book but
your Washington Post piece uh I think
was an important intervention uh and
you've obviously had Warren Farrell on
on here before and talked to him and so
I think you are one of the one of the
few public figures who have been willing
to engage in this issue in good in good
faith and and what I would say is a
positive way which does avoid exactly
that Zero Sum framing you've just
described which is this if we've
presented with this Choice like whose
side do you want effectively right and
they're even raising the fan there are
some areas where boys and men are
struggling means that you have to stop
paying attention to the areas where
women and girls are struggling is just
it's a nonsensical false Choice classic
a classic example of culture War uh
paralysis and actually you know my wife
for example is trying to raise money
right now
um for a startup and you you all know
some of these stories actually true but
you know so I know on a very personal
basis and the only two percent of
venture capital money goes to female
found right I'm reminded of that on at
least a daily basis and it's true and
it's a problem and then there are other
areas we could talk about where there
remain no problems in barriers facing
women and girls it doesn't mean we have
to then ignore the problem that's facing
Boys in that and it's a it's a false
choice and it turns out it turns out
people can think two thoughts at once a
politicians struggle to do that but more
Ordinary People are perfectly capable of
doing that yeah it's a symptom of our
polarized environment where it's like
choose a side and then you know you you
wind up in this inflamed environment uh
when I was running for president I
became very acutely aware of the issues
facing boys and men and one story that
did come across my my desk from Warren
Farrell was that there was another
democratic presidential candidate who
said I can't talk about this because I'm
in a Democratic primary
[Laughter]
in my mind perverse
um and messed up so let's dig into the
problems that you identify so broadly
speaking it's school and its work and
you have some prescriptions for each so
let's start with school boys are
struggling at school uh from the get-go
essentially K-12 uh the stats are
staggering I will confess that I am a
dad of two boys mine are much younger
than yours it sounds like yours are in
their early 20s yeah mine are nine and
seven
um but the the data around boy
struggling in school and being immature
in their brains forming later jives with
the experience of just about every
parent and family I know where if you if
you have girls of the same age
interacting with your boys you're like
wow these girls seem like
a hundred times more with it than my
boys and you and you don't you know you
don't like necessarily impugn your boys
by saying that I mean like that like a
lot of folks are having very similar
experiences but unfortunately that's
playing out
um in schools writ large yeah and I
think it's it's a a really interesting
example of how it took the women's
movement it took progress on behalf of
girls and women to to expose some of
these differences and so as you say
there are these big gaps so you know a
few data points that you know well but
uh in college for example the college
Gap is huge now the the the percentage
difference between the women getting
four-year college degrees in men is now
15 percentage points in favor of women
and that compares to a 13 percentage
point gap in favor of men in 1972 when
Title IX was passed to help women and
girls among those with the highest GPA
finishing High School two-thirds of
girls and among those are the lowest GPA
two-thirds of boys in the average school
district in the US now girls are almost
a great level ahead in English and and
have matched the boys in math so this
there is sometimes this idea well girls
are better at some things boys are
better at other things well basically
now that's not true basically just girls
that matter everything
um and that great catching up and
overtaking has exposed the ways in which
the education system actually doesn't
suit boys very well and particularly for
the reasons you've identified and again
like I have a three boys raising them
through adulthood and it is just a fact
that they the parts of their brain do
develop a little bit later on average
and it is the bit of your brain the
prefrontal cortex that is the bit that
says finish your homework don't go to
don't go out partying oh and also turn
in your homework the next day oh and
also maybe study for that test because
that test will affect your GPA right and
your GPA matters for your college
admissions and getting into college
might matter for your future so it's
about future orientation and there just
is there's a difference between boys and
girls and it's it's one of those things
where you have all this evidence from
neuroscience and you know the all the
psychologists and then you you share all
that with teachers and parents and
principals and they go well duh like
it's basic plan is not it's not
surprising to them but we ignore it in
our education policy like why why is
that fact is so obvious to everybody do
you ignore it in the way that we
structure and time education for boys
and girls yeah so you have a a number of
recommendations three big ones which I
all agree with frankly number one is the
most interesting and I think has gotten
the most publicity which is Redshirt the
boys let's just have boys start school a
year later uh the other two just so
people have a sense of it
um it is to uh invest in vocational
education
uh and the the third was drug my memory
uh more male teachers
yes is this is just an education those
are the three big education ones that's
right yeah yeah so what is the response
been to Red shirting uh boys for a year
which I think is a great idea uh you
know I've advocated for a gap year
um as an example heading to college
because the maturation serves people
really well yeah that is that is an
alternative for people who proposed
including in the UK there's been this
debate about should you know should you
have this Gap year especially for boys
but my view is that we should just start
earlier right if we if we know that that
Gap is coming if we know that
developmental Gap is coming and it's
particularly wide in adolescence why
don't we just anticipate it right so
your your idea is better than doing the
Gap year later because a lot of the data
shows that the boys are struggling
earlier on and you want to actually have
a foundation enjoy learning not have
Behavior yeah Etc yeah I mean my view is
that in there rather than letting them
fall behind and then try and catch up
later why don't we try and help them
keep up right it's easier to keep up
than to catch up and so I think we start
them in in school a year later it means
that just developmentally they'll be
closer to equal right so one of these
weird things like the chronological age
that we choose to start kids in school
is very arbitrary uh it's a proxy for
development but it turns out that it
differs on average between girls and
boys and so let's actually just bake it
in from the beginning I think it's one
of this it's one of those suggestions
that sounds incredibly radical to a lot
of people except every parent and
educator and principal I've spoken right
so they all go yeah of course you should
do better to them it's blindingly
obvious
um but of course it would need to be
piloted and evaluated but that's the one
I think that's interesting that's got
some more pushback interestingly other
the others in theory the idea that we
should spend more on vocational learning
and the fact that we should at least try
and arrest the decline in the number of
male teachers in our classroom most
people are like they're on board with
both of those ideas the red shirting one
is a little bit more controversial I
would say and there are good arguments
against against the policy as well as in
favor of it which I try to take
seriously in the book
um but overall what I'm being pleased by
is the when people are disagreeing what
they're saying is I don't think that's
the best way to help boys
okay right let's have a discussion then
about the best way to help boys but at
least we're having the conversation now
about boys which means we've accepted
the fact that they might need more help
foreign
from our sponsor betterhelp here at
forward we like to focus on Solutions
not problems but the fact is sometimes
our brain itself doesn't want to get
into problem solving mode it gets stuck
it focuses on the negative and not the
positive and sometimes your friends and
family really aren't equipped to help
you into a better frame of mind when
you're in that state you should really
think about therapy I saw a counselor
when I was a teenager and have been a
huge believer in therapy ever since and
if you're thinking of giving therapy a
try better help is a great option it's
convenient accessible affordable and
entirely online and you can get matched
with a therapist after filling out a
brief survey and then switch therapists
at any time when you want to be a better
Problem Solver therapy can get you there
visit betterhelp.com Yang today to get
10 off your first month that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash Yang give it a try
what's the downside it
is
[Music]
now it's one reason why your work is so
valuable Richard is that you you're an
unimpeachable
uh resource you know like it's it's hard
for people to dismiss you out of hand
um the way in this environment
unfortunately like a lot of folks who
stand up and say hey there there are a
lot of struggling boys and men out there
um you you can be marginalized as a
crank or like a neocon of some kind or a
culture Warrior yourself
um where the the data is very clear I
mean you know like the the struggles are
are very very
um real now uh one of the things you
just said is that 57 of college students
are now women I think it might even be
59 or 60 in them it's about 60 now yeah
so having a three to two female to male
ratio
um means that there's going to be a very
very tilted dating Market uh on college
campuses and then it's uh going to
actually persist when you graduate from
college so this is something you didn't
talk so much about I mentioned it in in
my book which is that college educated
women essentially do not marry
non-college-educated men for a whole
host of reasons
um and so you wind up with a lot of
mismatch in the dating market and this
is obviously assuming people are
heterosexual I mean there are a lot of
uh homosexuals so you know that like
this doesn't apply
um to the entire cohort but it largely
applies
um so you wind up with a whole host of
college-educated women who effectively
don't have mates and you also have a
host of college-educated men who
essentially have been primed to be jerks
because because cause what what one of
the like the empirical findings is that
if men have advantages in the dating
Market their behavior towards women gets
worse
um and then the reverse is true that if
if uh women have their pick of guys then
the guys all behave a lot better
or at least the guys who have a chance
at the dating Market behave a lot better
yeah
um so so this was something that uh I
I'm sure you noted because you did a ton
of research for this book
um but it was it was something that
I think people don't realize is an
outgrowth of the mismatch on college
campuses people can look at the 60 40
women men say hey that's a little bit
messed up
um but it actually has profound
Downstream effects well it might uh one
of the reasons why I don't address it is
because I'm I'm I'm less convinced than
than you are at this point that it is
going to be an issue for dating and I'll
say a bit about my way I mean I think
the first thing is like it's very
interesting if you talk to admissions
officers and they're now on the record
about this if you go past 60 40 uh in
terms of your female male ratio it
starts to affect admissions it turns out
that actually it becomes less attractive
both for men and women to go to a very
female dominated campus and so there's a
lot of people that desperately they're
desperately trying to keep their gender
ratio closer to at least at least closer
to 60.
um and that might well be because of
just how it feels to be on campus right
um and assuming that of course
heterosexual dating that it affects the
for sure it's effective dating on
college campuses no question about that
whether it will roll forward into the
late Market we just don't know it's a
bit early to tell we did just pass a
historic moment which is that now there
are in most marriages then the woman is
more educated than the man and obviously
we're going to see an increasing that
trend line is going to increase the big
question is are women with college
degrees really going to prove reluctant
to marry a guy without a college degree
right historically we haven't had to
answer that question because of the
historic imbalance we're now starting to
ask it I'm a bit less pessimistic than
some are I think that I don't think
they're going to want to marry someone
who's economically disadvantaged as well
but I think it's perfectly possible to
imagine a world where you have a woman
who's a nurse say so she has really has
a degree in nursing and I can think of I
have friends in this situation is she
going to marry a guy who's got his own
Plumbing business that's making good
money or is she going to say no no no no
he has to have a four-year college
degree I I don't I don't think so
um so I'm not as worried about it yet
and then the final thing that I'm makes
me more optimistic is the college
educated women and college educated
member they're really Keen to make sure
the kids do well
and one of the reasons they'll marry is
because obviously two is two earnings
are better than one they are convinced
that fathers and mothers are both
important and so the drive to marriage
among the college educated the marriage
rates are very high amount of college
educated America it's really high
I think that's largely because of
parenting and I don't think that's going
to go away so what's happening is people
projecting forward this difference in
colleges into the dating market and and
I think prematurely panicking ask me
again in 10 15 years whether my optimism
is misplaced but that's that's for me
not really the main reason to be worried
about this I think it's because it's
tough tough to be in the labor market
without a good college degree I will say
one thing I haven't thought about this
before Andrew but you just mentioned by
saying heterosexual of course does raise
an intriguing possibility the single
biggest cause of the rise in lgbtq
identification is the rise in the number
of young women describing themselves as
bisexual so you could speculate that if
to the extent that that's the case well
made maybe what you're going to see is a
rise in the number of same-sets at
relationships as college educated women
pair up with other college-educated
women rather than having to trade down I
have no real I have no empirical data to
support that but it's an intriguing
possibility so the other two solutions
that you you argue for it was
interesting that male teachers do
improve results for uh male students and
female students
um show no difference
um uh so it seems like male teachers is
an empirical win and I hope that we do
try to get more men into classrooms and
vocational schools uh seem to help male
students and less so female students but
that is not a reason to not invest in
them
um helping male students is a major
major win at this point if they're the
ones struggling it comes back to what
you said a moment ago which is like if
you just approach this like in a fairly
boring way which is huh here's a group
that seemed to be struggling here's a
here's a policy that seems to help them
unlike free college by the way which
doesn't seem to really move the needle
for male college going uh actually
Technical and vocational training is a
rare example of an intervention where
the benefit does really seem to accrue
more to boys and men than to women and
girls and you could you know you could
see that as a bug but you know I see it
as a feature given the current trends
facing board it's like why is why is
that a bad thing and so one of my
proposals is to create a thousand new
technical high schools there's about one
and a half thousand now and you know
even with right pretty you know pretty
uh big assumptions about Federal funding
you could probably create a thousand
high schools for about five billion
dollars a year with some federal
subsidies that would double the number
of students who can go to a technical
high school and five billion is one
percent of what the college loan
forgiveness program with book cost
conservatively right wow so for one yeah
one percent of the cost of forgiving
College college loans we could create a
thousand new technical high schools and
that would take up the number of
students in them to about 15 and the
biggest beneficiaries would be boys and
especially boys in working class Mac
Marines and so that kind of policy
should be on the table
um and the fact that it
disproportionately helps boys should not
be seen as a reason to not do it it
should be as a reason to do it as well
as doing a bunch of stuff to help women
and girls again back to where we were
before like we can think two thoughts
for once and we can do two things at
once now one of the most interesting
findings in your book was that a host of
policy interventions don't seem to work
like if you've you just mentioned free
college and it turns out that a bunch of
girls in Kalamazoo took full advantage
of that but boys did not yeah um and
there were other programs that had the
same results uh whether it was tutoring
or retraining or whatever the heck it
was
um that it seems like when you try and
help a population
uh broadly the girls and women are in
position to take advantage but for
whatever reason boys and men it just
doesn't seem to to click or work yeah
this is I think that's politely because
like it's within mainstream education
the the a lot of these interventions are
tried but but and it's not much
discussed it's well known among the
people whose job it is to evaluate these
interventions but it tends to be in the
final paragraph and people will say oh
we should do more work on this but it's
not really discussed much and the free
college one is the one that really first
caught my eye so Kalamazoo has a
frequent every kid that graduates from
high school in Kalamazoo gets full
tuition paid pretty much any college in
the state is very generous but more
importantly it's the only free college
program that's had a really high quality
evaluation longitudinally by a bunch of
Scholars from upjohn and as you just
indicated actually increased the college
completion rates for women by 50 which
is a massive impact an increase the
college completion rates for men by zero
it literally didn't move the needle
overall for men which is an
extraordinary finding like making forage
completely free and so I think that
speaks to first of all look the guys are
struggling in education generally and so
just solving the financial aspect of it
doesn't solve the educational problems
but I also think it speaks a bit to
motivation and incentives you know what
the young women now and you you could
probably speak to someone from your own
experience but I I know talking to my my
son's friends more generally there's a
really strong script for young women
there so very a different scriptures on
their mums their mums or grandmothers
were it was you're going to be a wife
and you're going to be a mother maybe if
you work it will be part-time but that's
your primary role a new script for women
is get educated become economically
independent become empowered and make
sure you can stand on your own two feet
it's a really positive powerful script
for young women now it's Fant and
wonderful in one of you but what's the
script for men now we've torn up the old
mail script for good reason in me what's
the new mail script where's the where's
the sense of you know ambition and where
are the messages we're sending to our
boys about about their education and
their independence their empowerment and
the answer is we're not and so then they
end up drifting and it's not their fault
it's our fault
foreign
we all want to lead a happier healthier
more productive lives one of the ways to
do that is to make sure that you're
getting the sleep you need and one of
the best ways to get the sleep you
deserve is to have a high quality
mattress from Helix sleep the Helix
lineup includes 14 unique mattresses
customized to you you take a sleep quiz
and find out your perfect mattress in
under two minutes and then they will
send it to you when you have a hundred
night risk-free trial that's right you
can sleep on that thing for three months
and then send it back but I'm pretty
sure you're not going to want to send
anything back because the Helix Sleep
mattress is the hit mattress in my
entire house people fight over it every
night we have death matches around who's
going to get that mattress we don't do
that but I gotta say it is the number
one mattress in our house and the number
one mattress picked by GQ and Wired
Magazine so there are a lot of people
that love Helix sleep and Helix is
offering up to two hundred dollars off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners go to Helix sleep.com
slash Yang with Helix better sleep
starts now
[Music]
and this goes into uh your analysis of
both the left and right approach to
the struggles of boys and men uh and you
very interestingly characterize
correctly in my view that the left tends
to assign uh accountability to systems
for the failures of groups with the
exception of boys and men but where when
like if a boy or man screws up then it's
because they're individually noxious uh
or badly behaved and your argument which
I think is correct is look like if
you're going to apply that framework it
should apply to boys and men too and
that this is not just a Cascade of
individual failures that they're
actually structural issues that if
you're serious about trying to build you
know uh an equitable Society you should
be thinking about these issues the same
way yeah it's a it's a rare this is an
instance of agreement between left and
right although in different ways they do
basically individualize the problem and
as you say on the left that's that's
pretty rare typically the left will
point to structural structural barriers
structural problems but in this in the
case of poison men it can be the result
of toxic masculinity or there'll be
stereotypes about well they just want to
watch they don't want to look at porn
and play video games and smoke weed
they're just losers you know men attract
hashtag may not trash
Etc you even saw that in covid and men
were dying and much higher numbers of
covid that was that was blamed on them
and completely unfairly or this
pejorative term in cells uh involuntary
settlement and Bill Maher made a joke
which I could relate to certainly as
like a nerdy Asian kid is that like we
all start out as involuntarily celibate
you know
and end up the you know the somewhat
fortunate among us maybe you know like
end up having some opportunities or uh
you know like uh be able to gain
confidence in a particular Arena
um uh but then if you don't then you can
get stuck very easily and you point out
the international phenomenon of kind of
the shut-in men of Japan of which there
are hundreds of thousands
um and there it's a documented
phenomenon but in the U.S it's kind of
maligned as like oh you're like these uh
in cells and instead of being a
sympathetic figure you're a malignant
figure
um now the the danger of course is that
if you have a real problem and you you
say this in your book and I think this
is very very important it's like look if
you have a real problem and responsible
people don't try and help it then
irresponsible people will just go right
in and say hey okay you know you're
you're upset you're marginalized here's
why and then they'll drag you down some
uh conspiracy theory internet rabbit
hole and radicalize you and we have many
many young men who are now uh
unfortunately receptive to that because
they're at home and angry yeah I think
to that extent the the Mana sphere as
it's sometimes referred to which is a
sort of conglomeration of ins you know
so-called in cells men going their own
way pick up pick up artists you know
there's this guy Andrew Tate who's going
to become a who's been banned on lots of
platforms but incredible viral videos
which are just sort of this incredible
misogyny
um you know funny in some cases and so
on but I think that that's our fault we
we as in like mainstream institutions
Etc have created that market and of
course if you create if you create that
market then someone's going to supply it
we've created it by not discussing these
issues not confronting them not actually
acknowledging hell yeah here are some
issues facing boys and men and here's a
bunch of things we're doing to address
them and so what that means is that when
the irresponsible people say
no one cares about you right no one
cares so here's a young man right you're
struggling you're struggling in the
dating Market maybe you're struggling at
school you're struggling to find a way
in the world and then someone comes
along and says that's because the left
hate you because the mainstream media
hate you the elite just think you're
toxic there's enough plausibility to
that claim
to drag that young man deeper and deeper
into the manosphere because he does look
around and he doesn't seem you know
responsible people addressing his
problems and to the extent that they're
addressed at all it is to blame him it
is to say there's something wrong with
you you're toxic or irresponsible and
there's all these stereotypes and one of
the results of that is greater isolation
for young men Etc but rather than
pointing the finger we should be
offering a helping hand
and in different ways both left and
right they're pointing fingers and and
and actually you know but it's
particularly frustrating for those on
the left to do it who who actually is
you indicated make a point of not doing
that in other circumstances and saying
look what's Happening Here what are the
structures around you are the
institutions serving you well now what's
the script you're following how are we
supporting you as a site how are we
empowering and affirming you as a
society right and and then tackling all
of those things correctly for people of
color or lgbtq or whatever but we've got
to do it for young boys and men too the
default assumption that we've done is
just wrong if we neglect them and
neglect the issue
we have created the circumstances in
which men might shut in check out or at
work get pulled into some pretty dark
places and so that as I you know I think
it's incredibly important we take
responsibility we have a cultural
responsibility to address this issue
yeah I I totally agree
um so we've gone through school uh on
the work side
um you and I both know that we've lost a
lot of manufacturing jobs and those jobs
were 70 male similarly transportation
jobs and uh construction and
installation jobs uh also predominantly
male and some of these roles are either
being automated or globalized away
um you had globalization at I think two
million jobs
um just one objective fact is that we
have four million fewer manufacturing
jobs in the United States than we did
um at an earlier point in time and so if
70 of those workers were men then you
have a whole lot of men who now now
don't have those jobs and their next
step has been unclear in a lot of
communities there is this work imbalance
and yet at the same time some of the
most visible Fields whether it's Finance
or Tech or law or Consulting continue to
be male dominated and so there's this uh
this bifurcation going on that falls
largely along educational lines it falls
along Regional lines it falls in
different Industries and the net effect
has been that there are many many men
who are on the outside looking in
because of a transforming economy but
their struggles have not actually been
highlighted or brought to the fore yeah
I think that's right and I think it
speaks and obviously you've done a lot
of work in in this space and you have
your own policy ideas about how to
respond to this shock or I think it is a
shock kind of thing you've talked about
it in that way like this is the labor
market has just the Automation in
particular and to some extent Freedom
just that massive shocks to the economy
which we're not responding to we're just
we just you know whatever you think the
solutions to that are whether it's Ubi
or whether it's you know some of the
proposals I've gotten here like the fact
that we need to respond I think is is
the is the most important fact and
you're quite right that what's happened
is the these Autumn both of those shops
have disproportionately affected men
especially working class men and the
adaptation that's required to flourish
in the new economy has been one that
many men have struggled with uh and I
also think it's one of those we haven't
really worked on women are moving more
quickly into some of the newer jobs they
were already in jobs that were more
acted from Automation and trade in some
of the more Hands-On type jobs so they
were less affected anyway but actually
helping men to move into and retrain for
the new jobs is absolutely right and
here here I think is where the right
actually acquire responsible because to
the extent that they do engage with the
issues of boys and men it's typically to
to then imagine that they can wave a
magic wand and bring back the jobs of
the past so Senator Josh Hawley you have
a big speech about men and at the end of
it he said we'll have a tax break for
marriage which is Bonkers and doesn't
work and we're going to bring back
Manufacturing
like well where's your magic one turn
back the clock no problem we have a time
machine Richard let's just I mean move
it backwards it's incredibly
irresponsible because what it does is it
sends a signal that yeah yeah vote for
me and I can bring back the world as it
used to be which of course you can't
these Trends continued under Donald
Trump right there is no president who
can Jawbone the economy of the 50s back
into existence but what it sells is it
sells its false perspectives of of I can
a rear view mirror politics and rather
than saying okay here are some real
problems here's how we're going to help
you address them and so to the extent
that the right does even they
acknowledge the problems of poison but
they typically to either blame feminists
blame women blame modernity
Etc and then say don't worry we'll bring
back we'll bring back the 50s which
nobody wants even if we wanted it we
can't go back in the time you know
unless you've got that time machine
behind you somewhere that you can bring
out send it to Senator Josh Hawley which
he doesn't want by the way I mean his
own wife is incredibly successful
professional nobody even the most
conservative person doesn't want the
world of complete gender equality and
really doesn't want to turn around
even if they knew how to
uh so the marriage rate among
non-college-educated Americans has
plummeted uh to below 50 percent which I
think is a very crucial threshold or now
a majority of Americans don't expect to
get married maybe they expect to get
married but they won't get married
um and this winds up having some very
negative effects on the Next Generation
you have a lot of data on boys and girls
growing up uh with out dads it turns out
that dads are a plus as a dad I felt
pretty good about that that that that
that and more and more people recognize
that having a dad present uh is
incredibly important for all sorts of uh
positive outcomes for kids and you have
a number of recommendations uh in that
direction around trying to establish
fatherhood as a different type of
relationship than a purely economic
relationship which is the way it's
codified right now in a lot of
circumstances yeah so I agree that is I
mean you pointed at this huge plus Gap
in marriage which we've kind of alluded
to earlier it's really interesting and
that in and of itself is an important
data point that that it is the most
economically powerful women
arguably in the history of the world I.E
College educate American women who are
marrying and staying married at the
highest rates which is not what Gloria
Steinem or anybody else predict even
Gloria Steinem just got married
right that's a that's an interesting
moment in a dog itself meanwhile as you
point out that for Less educated
Americans it's actually much more common
to not to not get married and certainly
not to have children inside marriage so
the non-marital birth rate among
non-college educated Americans as you
say is now above 50 now what does so if
we assume that fathers matter and then
it turns out as you just alluded there's
good evidence that farmers matter
interestingly especially you know
there's really good evidence that matter
to teens especially like so you're
coming up to this point Andrew you've
matted all along but you're going to
matter even more over the next you guys
it's my time to shine coming up Richard
Here Comes Andrew because it just for
whatever reason dad's matter throughout
childhood but but I sometimes fear the
way we talk about kids is that we think
it's game over at the age of five right
uh and we do we we ignore the huge
importance of adolescence which is
actually look looks like dads might have
a sort of some special powers when it
comes to adolescence well I certainly
had no special powers when it came to
infants
your social power up might be is to just
be there doing your bit but the so
they've got so far this math involve
father's matter so and what we see is
this real rise in fatherlessness in
other than the kids who who don't see
who don't see their father so within uh
within six years of their parents
separating a third of American Kids
never see their father yeah it's another
third another third team once a month or
less and so what happens as the
relationship between the parents breaks
down or perhaps didn't exist in the
first place the relationship the
relationship shipment that gets that
gets destroyed is the one between the
father and the kids and if the father's
not a breadwinner in particular he
basically gets benched right so if we
continue to see the role of the father
as this married breadwinner and
increasingly men are neither of those
certainly not that Soul Brethren anymore
women are the breadwinner and more than
40 Main bread and more than 40 of
households so what we do is we end up
benching the dads and so what what a lot
of social conservatives would say is
that's why we need to bring back
marriage right the way to tie men to
Children through marriage right we need
to restore marriage well a I don't know
how we're going to do that B I think
that's the genius out of the bottle on
there and so what I think we need to do
instead is build father for government
as an independent social institution
fatherhood needs to be put back on a
pedestal just a different kind of
pedestal I mean to say to dads and
communicate through policy to dads and I
have some ideas on that
that you matter as a dad period not just
as a not just a breadwinn are we all too
often treat Fathers as walking ATMs
particularly in our child support system
and forget about the relationship
between the fathers and children and
that that not only matters even if the
father's not living with the kid but
especially if they're not I found one
really interesting study that found that
kids whose parents are separated but
they have a strong relationship with
their father and spend a lot of time
with their father actually do better
than the households where the father is
present but they never see them and they
have a very distant relationship yeah
that was a compelling study I was like
wow a good dad outside their home who
actually shows up and cares is better
than the present dad who is totally
checked out and I that was because I
actually thought having a dad in the
house was like an intrinsic win well I
think I think look I think it is to the
extent like the dad's in the house it's
obviously easier for him for him to have
a closer relationship right so I
wouldn't deny it makes it easier but
what it exposes is that what's really
going on here is it's the relationship
and so this idea of absent present and
absent father can't just be described by
is he living with the mother or not
right actually my my first marriage
ended in divorce so I have a child from
uh from my first marriage and I was
incredibly involved
um with my eldest child very very
um strongly in his life it took a lot
but of course it was harder it took a
lot of work and I think the problem is
if if we continue to say it must be
married must be living with the mom when
that's just not the case for so many now
in fact it's only the minority of
American kids now who all who will grow
up throughout their childhood with both
biological parents and so look this is
yeah this is as it is and again I
having made these massive changes to
family structure I don't think we can
just sort of turn back the plot and in
the meantime we're just leaving too many
kids without a strong enough
relationship of the father so equal
equal paid leave of mothers and fathers
a really radical reform of our child
support system that that really has not
kept pace with the changes in families
in the U.S now one of the major changes
you Champion is that the same way
philanthropists uh and elected officials
get excited about women in stem we
should get excited about men and heal
Ben can heal where heel stands for
healthcare education Administration and
literacy uh and you make this really
really
a striking comparison that there are
more jet fighter pilots who are women uh
at this point on a percentage basis than
there are kindergarten teachers that are
men many more
yeah and and that male teacher uh pays
off in in various ways and so uh we want
to try and make it so that men can go
into the classroom the hospital other
environments that are considered right
now sort of the domain of women
um I suppose in part because these
sectors one need men uh but two these
industries are much less subject to
automation uh they're much more
resilient uh they they have much more uh
sustainable long-term prospects yeah and
it's interesting how how you frame this
argument like what's the what's the most
compelling way to argue for the need for
more men in these professions the the
heal professions as opposed to stem it's
worth saying that even as we've
increased the number of women in stem
with further to go for sure at least
tripled uh the number of women I think
it's up to 27 28 women in stem now up
from like seven or eight percent
um the number of the share of men in
those heel professions actually dropped
and so fewer K-12 teachers are men only
24 of K-12 teachers are men now down
from 33 in the early 80s only one in 10
Elementary School teachers and you're
quite right as a chair of the profession
there are at least twice as many women
flying U.S military jets as they are men
teaching kindergarten
and I actually think that from a social
welfare perspective it's more important
to have men in kindergarten classes than
it is to have women flying fighter jets
I mean I
I'd like as many women flying fighter
jets as we can get but interesting we're
redesigning the clock pits of our
military planes to be more inclusive so
that people have particularly of
different heights can can so which would
actually help short men as well by the
way but but because it was excluding so
many women but I don't see us really
redesigning or spending much time to try
and get more men into our classrooms and
so there's just an asymmetry here and I
started off thinking look the main
reason to get more men into those jobs
is because of employment prospects for
them and I still think that's true for
the reasons you just said but I think
actually in some ways the more
compelling argument is because we want
the people using those Services whether
the health care education counseling
social care to have the option of having
a caring of the same sex it's been
really striking to me how many people
have like yeah I I I I try and choose a
school where my male teachers or
something we did my dad is in a care
home and when he needs to go to the
bathroom he actually prefers a guy to
Hilton but there are no guys and one of
the ones that's really really troubling
me given the mental health problems that
we have in this country and that you've
talked quite a lot about is the drop in
the number of male psychologists so if
you go back just to 1980 Psychology was
roughly 50 50. uh it's now 29 male
having dropped from 39 just in the last
decade and among psychologists under the
age of 30 only five percent are male so
if you roll that forward if you think if
you think it's important to have
counselors and psychologists mental
health professionals or both sexes
and I think it is I think it's important
right when I went to a therapist the
issues I was dealing with it was
definitely better that I was with a man
and and when you know some of my own
sons have had uh had issues and I've had
to seek some you know mental health
support definitely better with a man now
it that's not gonna be true for
everybody but pretty soon that's going
to be really hard to find and so I think
that just from the point of view of like
caring these caring professions are
caring for men and women boys and girls
and so it would be good if we had if we
had men in those roles like in schools
for example most student councils are
women most special needs teachers are
women
um but most of the people refer to
special needs and Men most substance
abuse counts as a women most of the
people refer to substance abuse
counseling are men and so there's these
there's these real disparities between
the provider and the user of those
services and so I think that that's a
really good reason why we should be you
know throwing money at this I would
here's the controversial bit I think we
should have male only scholarships to
get men into some of these professions
we should have subsidies for employers
that are diversifying their Workforce by
hiring more men just as we've done to
get women into stem we should be willing
to invest money and time and political
Capital getting men into these heel jobs
foreign
it's so important that you are trying to
Champion these measures that I think are
necessary in order for us to to address
uh the the structural problems it's
already happening at the college level
and you referred to it that colleges are
trying to keep men above 40 percent
um and there is
some putting of thumbs on the scales
by the way like there's some data that
shows that if they all of a sudden like
aren't allowed to to to tweak then the
percentage of men drops like there there
were a couple of studies or a couple of
schools maybe that said okay I'm not
allowed to consider it then all of a
sudden so so we're already doing it
softly we're doing it quietly
um and in many ways what your work is
allowing us to do is just to face facts
be like okay guys look if we want more
guys in the classroom probably going to
have to spend some money on it we want
more guys psychologists gonna have to
spend some money on it want you know
want some tech uh an apprenticeship and
Vocational and apprenticeship schools
that are going to help men we should
probably spend the money on it uh and
Men uh need it in various uh various
contexts one of the the chapters you
wrote that was a tough one to read
um was the situation for black men and
when you hear the word intersectionality
um right like the
the things that come to my mind uh are
not black men right now
um that that it it's used to talk about
how uh racism and sexism uh intersect uh
sometimes sexual orientation as well
but you make a compelling case that
black men are really being subject to uh
double whammy
um and that it's going to be impossible
for us to make meaningful progress we're
at large
um on something like closing racial
disparities without specific measures
targeting black men pretty much every
gender gap we've already talked about is
just Amplified
um when it comes to black men and women
so there's already two college degrees
going to black women for every one going
to black men black the wages of black
men have barely moved uh in the last few
decades white white women mean love
blown right past them so for every
dollar earned by a white woman a black
man ends 84 cents which is about the
same as the gender pay gap between men
and women and so that's why that's
That's a classic example of
intersectional analysis because what
we're looking at there is and race and
gender of course black women are a
little bit less than black men although
the gender gap is much much smaller in
terms of earnings and actually there are
more black women in the workforce than
men already black women are the
breadwinner in most black households the
main Breadwinner most black households
partly because of the some of the family
trends that you discussed earlier but I
think that like the the way
intersectionality is applied and how it
ought to be applied is what you're
getting out there because there is a
intersectionalities just like a game of
Stack it up right so you just keep
adding stack stack stack stack stack and
and you get you know X points to being
female whatever and it's just cumulative
but properly applied which I don't think
many of the intersectional theorists do
and even Kimberly Crenshaw herself who
find the term and works I don't think
she applies her own Theory
to its fullest extent because what it
means is that you should look at the
specific circumstances of different
groups and see how their gender say or
their race plays out and when it comes
to Black Americans
to me the evidence is pretty clear that
on most measures black men are worse off
than black women
and not despite being men but very often
because they're male
they face in all kinds of bias all kinds
of exclusion obviously they face the
incarceration highest incarceration
risks particularly during the War on
Drugs in the war and crime in education
they are basically the ones who are
struggling the most and compared whereas
black women actually doing pretty well
upwards Mobility black men are the least
upwardly mobile groups this is back to
some of my earlier work black women are
one of the most upbully mobile groups
out of the bottom quintile but then of
course in terms of households they're
they often struggle so in fact the
struggles of black men in fact black
women don't get me wrong but I think
that's intersectionality at its best and
what it means is that we can contemplate
in fact that black men might be actually
suffering as a result of being male
rather than benefiting from being male
that may not be true for Asian men or
white men or at least you know nothing
like the same extent then you could add
class then you could add geography but
what I think that it means is that we
just have to look at specific groups and
if we're serious about looking at groups
who are struggling
and we don't take seriously the
particular situation of black men and
boys then I don't think we're being
serious at all Yeah you mentioned this
uh White House Commission on gender
inequality
um and it's all about issues that are
facing women uh despite this this
relatively uh benign name that seems
like it would uh it would address any
form of inequality and I think maybe
your most important contribution is to
expand gender inequality to apply to
boys and men in certain contexts
um which is not the way a lot of people
use it I mean the way a lot of people
use it is that hey
um we have to help women and girls which
by the way I'm for in an environment
where we still need it we can think two
thoughts at once right I mean to be to
be fair so what happened was that the
Council on women and girls was abolished
by Donald Trump and then rather than
recreating that they created the camps
on gender policy Council which actually
did seem to open the door
to looking at gender inequalities that
run the other way some many of which
we've discussed but that didn't happen
so there's the first national strategy
on gender equality has been published
and it doesn't contain a single gender
inequality that runs against men and
boys so it is completely asymmetric I
think that's both wrong empirically for
the reasons that we've been discussing
but I also think it's just a massively
missed political opportunity like even
to have even just have a few areas where
you say look here is here is a place
where actually boys and men are on the
wrong side of the inequality and here's
what we're going to do about that would
really have blunted the attack the I
think the center left face which is that
they don't care about boys and men like
the way to blunt that attack is to show
that you care about boys and men uh and
the gender policy Council was a real
opportunity to do that and thus far it's
been a completely missed opportunity in
my view you talk about the dysfunctional
approaches on both sides where the the
progressive
uh side wants to
um ignore uh anything that that runs a
foul of a narrative that's uh you know
that that men are
um advantaged uh and then conservatives
are just trying to turn back the clock
and don't have any productive
um policy Solutions and a lot of it
hinges upon how how much you see the
role of biology like whether there are
intrinsic differences between boys and
girls and you make I think the very
reasonable argument that yes there are
genuine biological differences between
boys and girls uh related to risk and
um testosterone aggression uh and uh uh
sex but they're not all-consuming
dispositive like you know like that they
can be addressed and moderated by
culture
um and that there that there is not not
necessarily the word toxic in front of
the word masculinity
in every case like there's actually
there has to be a definition of
masculinity that is positive
um uh and I I think that's what most
people want it's one of the major
problems in my view of the current
polarized environment
um is that again you can't hold two
thoughts in your head like you can say
that look boys and girls are different
um but it's not that we need to accept
every difference as carved in stone and
that there are things that you can do in
terms of structural institutions policy
culture Etc yeah I think I think you put
it exactly right which is but on the
there's a fear I think particularly
among progressives in the center left
that even acknowledging any differences
in biology just you've given up the
phone right if you've given an inch
they'll they'll take they'll take a mile
and and to be I to be understanding of
that view it's because historically of
course but discussions of biological
difference have been used as arguments
against women they have been used to
justify sexist policies you know and so
I understand
concern but I also I also think that it
ends up being self-defeating to deny any
differences at all because anybody
that's like being in the world
realizes that's not true certainly
almost raised kids like well being a kid
or seen a kid
most people in my view
um no is there are these differences the
question is how much weight do you put
on them how much do they matter
Etc and so you get that so the left and
they they play off each other so the
more the left denies any differences in
biology the more the right emphasizes
that they are everything right but
they're everything's binary and by God
we're completely different and that's
why women should that's why women should
their homework after the kids and men
should be president and you know
commander-in-chief and stuff and so yeah
this is it's incredibly boring
tiresome kind of discussion because the
truth is of course is both nature and
nurture and more importantly recognizing
that there are some natural differences
you just highlighted some of them
doesn't in any way mean cultures less
important it means it's more important
because culture is one of the ways that
we learn how to express or not to
express these natural differences how to
bring out the good side of some of those
traits whilst acknowledging and
dampening the bad sides of those traits
so culture is how you grow up uh and so
the acknowledgment of nature makes it
even more important to take culture more
seriously and so let's take one of your
examples like Risk taking on average
boys and men are a bit more risk-taking
they're more willing and able to take
risks is that a good or a bad thing
neither
sometimes it's good because men are
willing to put their lives on the line
um they actually they're more willing to
Die to Save the life of a stranger
is that a good thing yeah I think that's
a pretty good thing but is it good when
they're a teenager and they do as one of
our friends kids didn't climb up a
eight-story crane and then send an
Instagram a Snapchat saying hey hi Mom
no no not good
um or some of the some of the ways in
which men take bad risks with their
health that's bad is it good or bad in
business that men are a bit more risk
taking well is good in the sense that
sometimes there's risks to pay off but
it's bad and it creates instability
and so
what we do as a society is we take these
differences that overlap and are on
average acknowledge them and then try to
try to bring out the best
in us whether that's masculine or
feminine uh whilst perhaps trying to
manage down the person honestly every
human society ever has been engaged in
that cultural task and I don't I think
it's incredibly arrogant of us to think
that we somehow don't have to do that
and we don't have to think about what a
pro-social masculinity looks like
because every other Human Society has
tried to do it and now we have to do it
in a way that's not only compatible with
gender equality but supportive of gender
equality that's what most people want
most people don't want to wash away the
differences they just don't want the
differences to become excuses for
inequalities yeah pro-social masculinity
indeed uh and one thing you said in the
book which I agree with is like look you
can't ask men not to be men you just
have to try and Define masculinity in a
way that uh is positive for them and
women uh and Society yeah and that's
what's being lost in the current debate
I think because on the one hand there's
a sense of masculinity is intrinsically
bad right and and no one to my knowledge
has come up with this satisfactory
definition of non-toxic masculinity that
is distinct from femininity they just
can't do it and so it becomes a slur
honestly to say toxic masculinity it
doesn't help to create what I think is
important which is mature masculinity
and actually I think I think what we're
seeing now is a celebration particularly
on the right of an immature form of
masculinity I think Donald Trump was
like an avatar and I kept thinking like
who does Donald Trump remind me of and
then I and then I realized it was my 16
year old sons and my 16 year old self
there was a sort of middle finger
transgressive boorish kind of just like
uncivilization and actually it's it's to
our great shame that that's appealing to
some people
um because it's so transgressive well I
think of him as the crazy uncle uh but
16 year old works too yeah well you're
right but it does to some extent it's
like the men who don't grow up right we
need grown-up men as well as grown-up
women and we don't get that by calling
them toxic or rolling our eyes at them
or caricaturing them or stereotyping
them we get that by taking seriously the
institutions in our society to help help
us all to mature and become you know
become better better human beings in the
end is what we're after and to the
extent that we are different as male and
female well let's acknowledge that
without turning it into some sort of as
you say dispositive
Richard I am so happy that you wrote
this book and that you're making this
case
um what has excited you or invigorated
you about the reaction to it what is the
reaction Ben
um I'm going to say you are the most
significant think tank in intellectual
figure to point out these facts uh your
stature is such that you know the New
York Times and others are are Reckoning
with the the argument I think you might
have the chance to mainstream the fact
that boys and men are struggling and
that it's a thing that we should be
trying to address in a way that perhaps
no one else has had that opportunity
um how have people been reacting to your
work well first of all thank you thank
you for saying that Andrew not only
because it's very it's a huge compliment
but also because it does speak to really
one of the motivations for the book
there's a book is about creating content
here's all these ideas here's these
facts you know here's this is these
studies I've read but honestly I also
think it's very much rating space
and one of my hopes and goals for the
book has been to create a bigger space
within which we can have this
conversation and to some extent a safer
space within which to have this
conversation because it can't be
dismissed as hopefully can't be
dismissed as the frothy ravings of some
you know men's right fringy person uh at
least not yet let's ask me ask me back
in a few months
[Laughter]
let's not give them any ideas Richard
but so far that's right and you're right
to some extent have a bit of insulation
uh coming out the gate around that I've
been incredibly pleased by the way in
which I've had engagement from left and
right
um but I probably most pleased by the
substantive nature of the disagreements
from the left
what has not happened is there just had
not just been dismissed
um as just like we don't have to engage
with this and so you mentioned the times
but David Brooks had a column in the
times to praise the book very well and
said he doesn't talk about culture
enough but Michelle Goldberg and a piece
of the times that that said actually
essentially said good social democracy
would solve a lot of these problems and
they spend far too much time on culture
and not enough on redistribution but
what was striking about that she said
look everyone knows there's a problem
here really
well and so okay I mean honestly that's
a huge moment that's a huge win
um and so the argument I'm having so far
with people is is about whether or not
I've got the right Solutions whether I
frame it in the right way but no one's
really trying to claim this is just made
up you know misogynistic nonsense and so
that in and of itself I think is a
really interesting sign my own view is
that there's a real appetite for a
proper station about this that hasn't
been on offer for certainly from
mainstream politics
um but that actually Ordinary People of
all classes all races are actually
really open to this conversation so long
as it's had in a good faith way you know
get our facts straight we can argue
about what we can argue about the
solutions
um but it's time to get serious about
this and I I'm sensing so far from the
response yeah and again Andrew you've
written about this yourself and so I
think you've helped to correct you you
yourself have helped to create the
conditions in which this book can land
um but I I'm I'm really pleased with the
seriousness of the engagement
especially with the disagreements
because if we're seriously disagreeing
about what to do about this that's huge
progress has anyone suggested a policy
or a solution where they said hey hey I
don't like your red shirt idea instead
we should do this or that like has
anyone actually suggested something
where you're like yeah that's a good
idea yeah so I mean one of the things
that gets suggested a lot in education
is Single Sex schooling but actually I I
looked at that and I just don't I just
don't find very strong evidence that it
makes
interesting really interesting to move
the needle very much and it's obviously
a much more radical reform than red
shirting I mean sending boys to the same
schools
as a parent
as a parent I could have chilled with
the kids for another year you know or
like just like found an environment I
mean you know like that there are pre-ks
now you just have them there for an
extra year it's tractable but actually
one of the uh one of one interesting
idea that someone had is that they
suggested that like there's these huge
gaps in high school GPA by gender of
course high school GPA is becoming more
important in terms of college admissions
as colleges go test optional so boys and
girls are basically they're dead dead
level now in SAT and ACT
um so but girls are way ahead and GPA
um and and on most other measures of
high school performance and so actually
GPA is becoming more important but
someone said to me that actually that
ninth grade is where boys uh really seem
to struggle and I've yet to sort of
really nail down the data on this so but
they said that's where you see a big gap
opening up so how about just ignoring
ninth grade and and just doing high
school GPA based on the grades after
that when boys are apparently doing a
little bit better and having had kids
who managed to get
I I don't know if I should say this out
loud but managed to get sub 2 gpas in
their freshman year at High School uh
right it's hard to recover your high
school GPA from that right I I have at
least two out of three sons who would
have done much better if we would just
we'd called ninth grade a watch Just
That Let's ignore ninth grade that's an
interesting little idea I I am
I am for this I am for both let's
Redshirt them and let's just X Out in
eighth grade from from gpas like you
know you're too too raw you're running
away from the seniors who the heck knows
and also let's try some of these things
and then evaluate them I mean you're a
wonk too oh I think Andrew and so I
think let's pilot some of these ideas
and then you know see what seems see
what seems to work there's some stuff
like technical high schools where the
evidence is already pretty good I think
it's good it's good enough so there's
some things where if like if President
Biden called me after this and said okay
I'm gonna I'm gonna register every boy
in the US I'd say hold on let's let's
suppose at first let's just see but if
he called me up and said okay I'm going
to spend five billion to create more
technical high schools I'd say go for it
you'd be like heck yes let's go yeah
yeah so I do think like the evidence for
some of it you know we have to be clear
that in some cases we just haven't done
enough of it to get good enough evidence
and because red shirting hasn't really
been pursued as a deliberate policy we
would need to do a bit more evaluation
but technical high schools
apprenticeships
you know paid leave for dads the
evidence is in right but those those I
would be like yes Mr President let's go
for it you know who knows my my phone
might ring right now Andrew and it could
be President Biden saying I I read yours
I I hope so I mean shoot man if I if I
were our president you'd uh all of the
stuff would be happening that's for sure
uh men and heal I think that the data is
also very very clear uh my my work
Richard is so that your work actually
becomes the dominant uh discourse and
approach to things
um because right now that what what
makes me so sad is that you have this
incoate uh polarization and people like
you know know this know that and
meanwhile uh like our families are
suffering and and you you said it in
your book you said look parents are as
worried about our kids uh you know
Americans are worried about their
families and then our leaders are stuck
in these partisan positions and roles
that have less and less to do with what
the heck is happening on the ground and
what's going to be good for us and our
communities so my work in life right now
is to try and improve the political
environment to a point where the
policies you're fighting for become the
law of the land in fact and common sense
it's like there are so many things where
you know you're pointing out all these
things that are happening to boys and
men I mean they've been uh creeping up
and and Rising for years and years
um I mean what Michelle Goldberg said
about a social democracy would that was
healthy would have been addressing these
things that is totally right
um so just kudos to you for an
incredibly important contribution uh I
hope everyone picks up of boys and men
why the modern male is struggling why it
matters and what to do about it and
Richard anything that we can do to help
you uh with your work please do let us
know because I I see this message uh and
your
now mainstreaming this set of concerns
as one of the most important things
going on in American life thank you very
much just having me on Andrew and thank
you for those words I really appreciate
it
[Music]